okay so I am Wow felicity is caught two
sub one of our professors he is going to
moderate this this panel and then would
have Luis Castaneda thank you so um
first I just wanted to thank that the
PhD students here at Columbia for
organizing such an impressive conference
and and also for inviting me to play a
part in it by moderating the session
which raises I think a set of questions
very close to my own current concerns so
I also appreciate that they gave me that
opportunity and it's taken each of these
papers they'll be it two quite different
ends are C problematics posed by by the
displacement of certain populations or
or really more precisely the sort of
violent uncoupling of relations between
territory and citizenship as it's
produced in the formation of new states
and then the terms by which is a key
figure of this geopolitical
transformation of course the refugee is
tactically mobilized or sometimes sort
of somewhat cynically forgotten by the
state that once in the register at once
as it manifests on the register of
architecture and urban organization and
just in case it's wanted to bring in one
contemporary example just in case we
need to be reminded of the degree to
which issues raised by architects
participation in the displacement of
populations and other environmentally
and justices often launched of course in
the name of development and often under
the rubric of the UN just in case we
need to be reminded of the degree to
which this continues at the point of the
present and you know speaking of course
above and beyond the sort of visibility
of events like Israel's construction of
housing in East Jerusalem not of course
you in sanctioned I just wanted to
briefly point to a rather disturbing
article in The New York Times
Wednesday's New York Times by Nikolai or
a soft and so then without questioning I
don't know people saw this I have a sort
of shocked of my morning coffee without
questioning the effects of displacement
other
mechanisms through which is about to be
wrought he's championing this plan by
the Haitian government the Haitian
government Development Agency to
decentralize Haiti to as he reports and
I quote we distribute large parts of the
population of port-au-prince to smaller
Haitian cities we find you men sort of
echoing the language of the so-called
open crisis of the 1960's and with it
ideals of architecture becoming
something like another technology of
counter insurgency strategies he goes on
to say that such plans and i quote could
become a reliable blueprint not just for
reconstruction but also for solving many
of the urban ills and he cites Leslie
Voltaire who's a Hades special envoy to
the UN that otherwise portal plans that
I quote will become an incubator for
further crime and violence and then we
find that uncannily repeating the
opportunism that of course emerged in
the wake of Hurricane Katrina that under
the threat of environmental pressures
that the guidelines and the society oris
of the guidelines treat the recent
disaster is an opportunity this is a
good thing for him an opportunity that
is to argue for the redistribution of
the poor and the language of
environmental concerns an urban security
so of course as he reports any notes a
sort of suspension of his usual distaste
for this trajectory of architectural
practice the Haitian team immediately
headed to the University of Miami where
the new Urbanists are of course more
than willing to capitalize on this
opportunity and help spread spread their
vision of city square as waterfront
parks and the clear separation of urban
of residential from other districts yes
oh video housing also and to come back
to the paradigm of development that your
housing the images of the new housing
then took the form of a sort of near
universal form of development
architecture yeah these basic shelter
prototypes that that are constituted
through core housing that would then
transition into more permanent dwellings
and so we find then if that the rapid
urbanization of Haiti initiated as
herself actually pointed out with the US
invasion of the country in 1915 that the
you know
very problematic contemporary us seven
models are now going to step in as a
panacea to that earlier invasion so I
just wanted to introduce each speaker
briefly like the other panels are going
to each presenting them will convene to
the table so Anu Anu siddiqui is
currently completing a doctorate in the
history of art and architecture at the
Institute of Fine Arts at NYU and heard
its dissertation aimed to develop a
critical history of she puts it the
architecture and urbanism of the refugee
she's the author of the library book
design collaborations in the public
schools on Princeton Architectural press
this is a book about an initiative that
she's been involved with to
revolutionize the culture of education
in low-income New York City
neighborhoods through innovative
instruction and library design she's
worked at both as an architect and in
non-governmental practice and is a
member of the activist Design Group the
Hester Street collaborative here in the
city and the title of a newspaper today
is exile and absorption urban
representations of refugees in the idea
of India welcome
did they spoken with that 13 OMG thanks
is it is a sound working okay thank you
everyone for coming and a special thanks
to the organizers for making this look
so effortless so the paper I'm
presenting today is part of a larger
inquiry into statelessness as a category
for architectural production and
interpretation that concerns the history
technology urban and architectural forms
and aesthetic practices that have
surrounded and engaged refugees since
World War two as that study focuses
primarily on post-war regions that are
within the purview of the newly formed
United Nations I became interested in
the Indian case as an alternate
situation in which the scale of the
refugee crisis had implications for
state identity but which did not operate
within the post-war rubric of an
international non-governmental presence
or network and just to provide
orientation this slide indicates the pre
national political geography of the
territory this illustrates the post
national condition this paper considers
the territorial effects of forced
migration at rural border lambs and
within the urban capital of the new
nation and the corollary impact on the
idea of India this idea mirrored a
concurrent construction of the notion of
Pakistan in this popular and political
construction Pakistan was a homogenous
religious state while India was
pluralistic secular intellectually and
politically independent and modern a
state that for instance might select a
la Corbusier to design one of its most
symbolic capital cities this paper is
predicated in part on the interpretation
that this binary opposition integrated
itself into architectural urbanistic and
territorial expressions of the Indian
state using as a vehicle the refugee
situation created by the territorial
partition that a come
independence the anticipation of
partition instigated mass migrations
during the waning months of the British
colonial period this map represents a
1946 proposal for India as a United
Federation and illustrates the bluntness
of the tool of depicting disaggregated
majority areas as a basis for partition
religious distinctions within regional
populations in the northwest and the
northeast sections B and C on this map
occurred much more finally than such
mapping represented and it's a little
hard to see but light the light shading
here depicts areas that were recorded as
Hindu majority and no shading represents
muslim-majority areas and the states
that were not affected by
nationalization are shaded dark among
the ambiguities of partitions South Asia
witnessed a territorial and communal
division that was not executed simply
during the moment of Independence but
over decades this continual
transformation over time destabilized
national territorial origins of
communities and legal identifications
for Refugees moreover different regions
and localities decolonized and
nationalized unevenly over time this map
indicates the heterogeneity of national
territories and existing kingdoms from
1947 to 1955 and roughly the color
demarcations depict Pakistan and green
and India in pink and blue with former
British provinces in pink and blue
representing princely states that
eventually merged into the indian state
refugees have typically been defined as
persons displaced or forced to migrate
across international borders but in the
indian case an international condition
applied only after independence captured
in lofty rhetoric and imagery the indian
nationalization occurred symbolically at
midnight on august fifteenth nineteen
forty seven but practically over the
course of the following decades becerra
is summoned there clarifies this fraught
contingency of citizenship in relation
to the definition of refugees on the
subcontinent
in contrast to the disruptions of
established nation-states in Europe so
glaring that they caused the formation
of an international order to address the
refugee problem South Asian refugees
were not actually quote seamlessly
folded into two new nations end of quote
as might be presumed the
conceptualization of the refugee in
local Indian languages reflects these
ambiguities through language summoned
are emphasizes quote in the Indian
subcontinent the figure of the refugee
was marked by religious community end of
quote as ravinder kaur analyzes in a
study of punjabi resettlement in delhi
the Hindi and Punjabi words for refugee
plan a gear or Sharon anthe referred to
anyone she seeking shelter or protection
even a traveler breaking a journey on
the other hand the order term mohajir
specifically recalls the flight of
Prophet Mohammed to escape religious
persecution involving his migration from
Mecca to Medina in 622 ad in Pakistan
xiamen their points out the charged or
do term actually formulated a legal
category of Muslim refugees quote such
that it left open and imagined Mohajir
return to India end of quote in India
the Hindi term for refugee is absorbed
into ordinary culture appearing commonly
as a qualifier for rest houses or panag
are on pilgrimage routes so with these
issues providing some background I'd
like to propose certain direct
territorial and urban consequences of
the mass displacement proceeding for
partition nearly 20 million people in
the subcontinent uprooted themselves and
fled in the wake of an unequivocal
popular and political realization that
decolonisation would not yield a unified
state the first occasion of mass flight
in 1947 followed the March 5th riots in
rawalpindi which is near present-day
Islam's Islamabad and migrations
continued until the formal announcement
of the partition territorial
demarcations two days after independence
on august seventeenth the migrations and
displacements persisted in the ensuing
days and weeks
british viceroy lord mountbatten had
appointed sir cyril Radcliffe the
general counsel of the English bar along
with regional boundary commissions
within the colony to draw national
border lines as the poet WH Auden
commemorated unbiased he was when he
arrived on his mission having never set
eyes on this land he was called to
partition in seven weeks it was done the
frontiers decided a continent for better
or worse divided Radcliffe had no
previous Indian connections or knowledge
of its territories and thus produced the
political appearance of offering a
valued impartiality in less than two
months Radcliffe and the boundary
Commission's performed would have been
described as vivisections of the
contentious regions of Bengal and the
Punjab joya Chatterjee debunks the
surgical metaphor is misleading she
suggests that it connotes a
dispassionate detachment or passivity or
a lack of collusion and culpability from
politicians from the subcontinent or the
conclusiveness of a single definitive
act as well as the technical procedure
implemented by specialists these maps
support that position showing evidence
of the malleability of the international
line proposed by international or by
internal political parties contributing
to the debate over the Bengal province
the shaded area here represents the
proposed Indian side and the unshaded
area of the Pakistani side the Muslim
League claimed claimed more Bengali
territory including the capital city of
Calcutta for Pakistan as Hindu groups
did for India as you can see in the
first two images Congress sought a
greater share of land for India as you
see in the third slide and the
provincial nationalist movement sought
to retain territorial integrity for
Bengal you see that in the fourth slide
highlighting its lasting effects on the
negative politics between India and
Pakistan ayesha jalal ensure that the
bose have criticized the awkward and
ambiguous topologies created by the
arbitrary divisions of the so-called
radcliffe line which is shown here as
the hard black line dividing Bengal in
punjab
two major provinces that were bisected
the boundary was derived using outdated
maps and census figures it depended upon
aerial views and very little on the
ground data tae-yong 10 explains that it
followed no natural dividing features
such as rivers or mountain ranges and it
cut across villages canal systems and
communication lines in the process
separating communities and bisecting
homes according to tan the mere six
paragraphs in the document explaining
the radcliffe award for the Punjab quote
wobbled from communal to economic to
strategic factors and of quote in Bengal
the line created non contiguous land
masses that inscribed a territorial
discontinuity into the new nations
willem van Schendel describes a
landlocked archipelago of n claves along
the northern border of Bangladesh then
East Pakistan including 197 territorial
islands that were decolonized and
nationalized that an uneven rate
inhabitants may not have fit neatly into
monolithic identifying categories of
Hindu or Muslim typically applied to
formally parcel the nations at the level
of municipalities consequently these
enclaves have hovered in a state of
political exceptionality sometimes to
this day for instance in this image the
chairman of an Indian Enclave and what
is now Bangladesh poses in front of his
house with each foot in a different
nation he eventually extended his real
estate with in addition to the house to
acquire a postal address and domestic
utilities from the Bangladeshi
authorities the process of affecting
borders in South Asia undergirded the
complexity behind the mass flights of
1947 also I would like to suggest that
it cast the border itself as a landscape
integral to the image of the Indian
state the paradigm of the political
boundary with Pakistan configured a
master narrative of the state in which
the refugee figured as a critical
protagonist away from the Indian
Borderlands exceptionalities on a scale
of neighborhoods houses and persons
mutated urban areas in
interior the refugee crisis keenly
impacted Delhi the so-called eternal
capital that was converting into yet
another seat of rule in the same moment
that the new Indian state was
appropriating monuments and
architectural symbols of power belonging
to the former capital city of both the
Mughal and the British Empire's a
staggering refugee influx catalyzed what
Ian n thereupon d cults the literal
transformation of Delhi into a refugee
is thought within a week of independence
a hundred and thirty thousand refugees
entered the city and within five months
four hundred thousand had arrived from
Punjab alone refugee populations
included Muslims fleeing into the centre
from rural districts around delhi and
Hindu and Sikh refugees from the Punjab
the inner city flooded with clashing
groups seeking refuge from communal
violence the formal urban elements of
Delhi's typically Islamic haveli or
mansion lined streets chokes or open
markets and mahala's the neighborhood
quarters transformed into violent
opposing refugee camps within ten days
of the independence festivities causing
curfew to be imposed within the old city
walls by August 25th and just to clarify
these are these images are not from 1947
during this crisis of law and order a
critical political dispute occurred over
real estate the fulcrum in a multiple
stage process by which city residents
turned into refugees in the immediate
aftermath of partition through arson and
forcible occupation by incoming refugees
from Punjab Delhi Muslims were
dispossessed of their homes and
businesses eventually systematically
through pogroms Muslim residents some
who held property for generations fled
for safety igniting the perception that
they were actually deserting for
Pakistan as a security measure the
indian state zoned safe areas for
muslims in the city you can see the
hatched parts of this map that are
typically in the vicinity of camps as
the influx of refugees from
his son forced an acute housing shortage
muslim zones began to be contested due
to the ambiguities of evacuations and a
perception that these neighborhoods
would serve as a fifth column for
pakistan some in their notes when it was
argued that empty houses should be made
available for the rehabilitation of
shelterless refugees it was clear that
housing Hindu and Sikh refugees was seen
as central to the task of rehabilitation
and that the process of rehabilitation
was to make refugees into citizens of
the state the state offered no immediate
parallel rehabilitation for des Lee's
Delhi's Muslim populations and
eventually institutionalized
dispossession through the custodian of
evacuees property this governmental
authority emerged in September 1947
under the premise of safeguarding
property for refugee return ironically
evacuate property legislation eventually
rarified this the displacements by
locking displaced persons in India and
Pakistan in an oppositional relationship
with each other refugees in both states
would be rehabilitated through the
granting of housing land and businesses
categorized as evacuate property in each
respective location foreshadowing this
multiple step process of creating
refugees the public called to
rehabilitate Hindu and Sikh refugees
within the Indian state accelerated
Indian Muslims desire and tendency to
migrate out of the country this promoted
on one side the perception of these
constituents as deserters and on the
other the sense that the Indian
government was unwilling to protect
Muslim persons properties and even the
neighborhoods demarcated for their
safety Delhi Muslims were quickly
pressured to seek refuge in the cities
camps either forcibly or for
self-preservation thus in the weeks
after independence the Exile of one
group an absorption of another caused
the capital of the new nation to
function as and project the image of a
camp the nation's locus of power also
became its line of frontier it's urban
spaces representing a transitional
station for incoming and outgoing
refugees
by September nineteen forty seven thirty
thousand muslims camped in the maidan or
the courtyard of the jama masjid a
prominent exterior urban room that for
three centuries had organized space and
society in the walled old city of
shahana bud and it's shown here in a
recent photo sixty thousand muslims
relocated within a matter of days to the
Citadel of purana qila where they would
embark for pakistan at the nearby
nizamuddin railway station due to the
violent attacks on rail lines and
passenger cars which were captured in
contemporary literature and and margaret
bourke-white photos to lahore ran only
by october of 1947 so put on akela
quickly emerged as an egregiously
overcrowded camp the largest muslim camp
in delhi the camp originated with 12,000
government employees awaiting relocation
to pakistan soon joined by evacuees from
the muslim safe zones initially the
indian state took no responsibility for
a camp tainted by the perception that
its inhabitants intended to desert the
nation which moreover was supplied with
food aid and security by the pakistani
government the indian government denied
basic provisions and left the facility
equipped with only one tap supplying
water despite a cholera outbreak until
gandhi visited on September 13th of 1947
afterwards the Indian government
proclaimed responsibility for the camp
and the intention to repatriate its
inhabitants as citizens the cap soon
evolved into a control mechanism
loudspeakers and policing systems
preceded water supply and sanitation
infrastructure the physical cross
section of the monument it's inhabitable
ramparts and enclosure recalled its
erstwhile purpose as a fortification and
as Burke White's image images captured
the landscape architecture recast perdon
Aquila as a monumental departure gate
for what has been called the last
journey to Pakistan in the refugee map
of deadly if purana qila cast a state
monument as a utilitarian shelter
converse examples in the following
decades suggest a monumental
of the ordinary Punjabi refugees
resettle in as Indian citizens later
renamed this area of the city in an
attempt to exert their identity on the
urban map a constituency that gained
power in municipal politics soon after
partition resurrected the Hindu legend
that the capital indraprastha from the
epic Mahabharata was located in the
vicinity of purana qila and that the
walls of this fortress were built by its
kings this legend may not have been
borne out by archaeological evidence
nevertheless the image of the poor
nikhila camp as the locus of pakistani
expulsion buttress the vision of a
political return to a mythical and pre
Muslim heritage for the nation's capital
robin de Bourgh has it recorded other
types of informal investment by Punjabi
refugees in symbolic territories and
everyday architecture of Delhi for
example in points that marked their
journey from Pakistan for instance
refugees entered the city via the delhi
railway station upon registration at a
building called the oval canteen the
destitute were given World War 2 surplus
tents while those with greater means
were housed in the concrete barracks of
the Hudson lines in kingsway camp which
are shown here in a recent photo this
barrack lodged sixty thousand persons on
the way to transitional settlements the
informal preservation of this
architectural memory by an emergent
bourgeoisie suggests establishment of
new founding myths with refugees as
pioneers of a new city to further map
the refugee landscape of Delhi it's
necessary to emphasize that in effect
they did found a new city after
independence refugees contributed the
lion's share to Delhi's unprecedented
growth census figures that were taken in
1951 documented an increase of 1.1
million people in a decade a hundred and
six percent growth from the population
in 1941 500,000 arrivals replace the
330,000 who left multiple agencies
operated to manage the except
of Delhi the newly formed Indian
Ministry of Rehabilitation acquired
undeveloped land ringing the city
accommodating 200,000 refugees on 3,000
acres within 20 colonies by the mid-50s
at 2 million residents the city sprawled
to the south and the West in 1954 the
state convened a committee to develop a
civic survey and master plan for the
city constituting the Delhi Development
Authority in 1957 through an act of
parliament and incorporating the
municipality of Delhi in 1958 to manage
infrastructural support through massive
building projects over two decades the
state finally declared refugee
resettlement in Delhi complete
abolishing the Ministry of
rehabilitation in 1965 the state's
eventual absorption of selected refugee
populations within an urban planning
apparatus delivered a conclusion to the
narrative of violence that cleaved the
city the uncertainties of religious
based zoning and the ambiguities and
contingencies of territorial
displacement but that narrative of urban
upheaval and resolution in the capital
city reinforces a certain reading of the
effects of partition and I'd like to
conclude with a few of its problematic
aspects first I believe that the state
cast the modernity of India as an
unstable proposition bound up with
extreme Mobility's and the political
uncertainty of a nation fabricated from
conditions of compromised citizenship
this staging has been useful for
constructing a denim on in which Empire
was ultimately vanquished by the self
actualized modern state for instance in
the symbolism of Allah Corbusier
designed to Chandigarh it's not
necessary to read Delhi's post-colonial
urban adventure as indicative of a
modernity in crisis on the contrary the
conditions of statelessness and the
circumstances of refugees might
interrogate the nation just as they give
imagery or urban form to the idea of
that nation outside of any question of
modernity second the very condition of
forced migration at the core of the
Indian nation has generated a
questionable account of the triumph of
the state
new constituency including what gar has
isolated as a popular discourse of the
indomitable refugee spirit this has
supported India's problematic cultural
hegemony over its neighbors and it's
contributed to the limitation of the
broader histories of other nations in
the region and in turn their access to
trans regional histories this includes
histories of architecture for instance
India not Pakistan traces of popular
claim to the Taj Mahal similarly
Bangladesh invokes no architectural
heritage outside its limited
geographical area although an undivided
Bengal was the seat of the British Raj
and finally the emphasis on the
partition narrative may further a
misrepresentation of the significance of
refugees to the nascent Indian state
with non border regions often barely
disturbed as historian David ledin
points out for most people partition was
a national trauma that affected people
far away in other regions nevertheless
the profound social and spatial effects
of partition refugees on particular
areas of national value namely the
capital city and its architectural
memories inflected the state's
mobilization of the event in its
rhetoric in mapping the urban impact on
the city of Delhi I've attempted to
register the place based specificity of
the events to situate statelessness as a
tool for critical architectural
interpretation of the Indian capital and
through it cultural expression of the
nation
thank you a new so i spec a second
speaker no I'm less room has recently
completed his PhD at the London
consortium the University of London and
holds an MA in cultural studies from the
Hebrew University in Jerusalem his work
deals with problems of urban and spatial
history in Israel and the relation
between urban transformation and
political dissent forthcoming
publications include a book chapter on
Israeli memory activism and a critical
essay outlining new perspectives on
spatial history in Israel the title of
his paper today is unsettled nationhood
between Arab houses and public tenements
in Israel Thank You felicity and thank
you the organizers for bringing together
such a fascinating day so far this is a
1959 construction plan for a
neighborhood in the outskirts of Tel
Aviv it is it seems utterly technical to
red rectangles marked the future
location of housing blocks the plans
intentionally intentionally schematic
nature creates an almost abstract
geometry shapes floating on a pristine
white background devoid of any feature
that ties them to the constraining
specificities of time in place despite
its modest proportions this plan
captures deeper motivations in the
imagination and production of the
Israeli space after the 1948
arab-israeli war and the establishment
of the State of Israel Zionists
architects and political ideologues were
keen to imagine the new territory as an
unspoiled clean slate that could be used
to realize national aspirations and
political ideologies this perceived
emptiness also legitimized the
eradication of the Arab landscape of
Palestine its physical presence as well
as its symbolic meaning the housing
blocks that came to dominate Israel's
urban landscapes for
the 1950s embodied this illusion of a
fresh start the establishment of an old
new national space according to strict
political and ideological agendas and
yet unlike the architects drawing board
the physical and cultural landscape of
Palestine was never cleansed completely
there was certainly depopulation and
vast destruction of the Arab built
environment during and following the 48
war however the idea that the Israeli
housing block emerges into or even
results in a blank space ignores the
fact that dozens of Arab villages and
neighborhoods survived the war and many
served house Jewish migrs immigrants
in the following years nonetheless this
resilience of the Arab space remains
largely overlooked according to state
planners these sites were temporary
remnants soon to be replaced by spaces
that fit the new national mission what
is even more striking is the way this
emptiness appears in more recent
accounts criticizing the biased ethnic
and political agendas behind Israel's
architectural history and these accounts
the emptiness is still there though this
time it is the result of the
orchestrated and deliberate destruction
of the Arab space according to this
characterization the housing blocks were
planted in emptied sites of ruination
much like national forests Israel
planted on the ruins of Arab villages
ironically in both official state
chronicles and in contemporary critical
scholarship the Arab house and the
Israeli block are seen as diametrical
opposite locked in an insoluble relation
of mutual negation in this paper I want
to argue for an alternative historical
analysis that highlights what geographer
Dori Massie calls the throne
togetherness of space instead of mutual
exclusion the analytical focus turns to
the forced encounter between the Israeli
block and the Arab house to shed light
on the protracted impact
this critical moment through a
discussion of one case study a de
populated Arab village just outside Tel
Aviv I want to point to the arduous and
lengthy process of urban spatial
transformation where political power and
status tidy ologies are exposed to
scootin e and contestation far more than
just incidental remainders of a powerful
state-driven operation these sites
provide critical insights into the
ambiguities that characterize the
attitudes toward the Arab space in
Israel both by state actors and
importantly by the Jews who made these
places their home as I show the moment
when the housing block meets the Arab
house is also a moment when challenging
new horizons of social action and
alternative political subjectivity begin
to emerge about the village Salome
located five miles east of the city of
Jaffa was the largest non-urban Arab
settlement and mandatory Palestine
although the village was completely
depopulated when it was seized by
Israeli forces in April 48 the vast
majority of the taos ha's and public
buildings remained intact as the Jewish
authorities struggled with soaring
immigration rates and thousands of
Jewish war refugees in the Tel Aviv area
Solomon's Arab houses provided an
immediate and welcome solution by
January 49 over 14,000 Jewish war
refugees and mostly Yemenite immigrants
were settled in Arab houses and into
interim camps built nearby it's often
sarcastically said that in Israel
there's nothing more permanent than
provisional measures settling Jews and
settlement did indeed began as a
temporary step to live alleviate the
severe housing shortage and
simultaneously block the return of
Palestinian refugees once alternative
housing solutions could be found the
authorities intended to demolish the
village the mundane appearance of
Solomon's houses meant that in the eyes
of Israeli planners it didn't qualify
for rehabilitation and
preservation either as a tourist
destination found in Jaffa or saffet in
the north nor to be transformed into a
picturesque artist colony like the
village of Ain hold near Haifa
nonetheless within month of its the
population the village was bustling with
life Jewish children attended to two of
the school's synagogues were open in
former Arab coffee shops and even the
large mosque that this mosque at the
center of the village was turned into a
youth club the following year and 49
what began as a state mission to grab
Arab land and property soon took a life
of its own with the Jews inhabiting the
village preventing by virtue of their
presence the demolition of the Arab
built environment this clash became
visible vividly visible in the contrast
between Solomon's Arab houses and the
new housing blocks that began emerging
around it in the decade that in the
decades that followed the 48 war the tel
aviv-jaffa metropolis sprawled and
expanded salome now renamed as the
Jewish neighborhood of FAL Shalem was
gradually engulfed by new neighborhoods
all comprised mostly of tenements of
various styles and periods as one critic
put it the conurbation that surrounds
fell Shalem is an ontology of public
housing in Israel from the late 50s to
the present this proliferation of blocks
and former Arab areas was part of the
broader state effort to abolish internal
discrepancies that hindered the
formation of the homogenous at no
national space expressing more than just
the new aesthetic ideals the housing
block epitomized the widely held
conviction among Israeli planners and
politicians that all right that
political socialization and the
hamadryad homogenize ation of the
national community could be determined
and manipulated through centralized
housing policies Solomon was just one of
many places targeted by this
rehabilitating spatial politics it
unlike many other Arab
villages and urban neighborhoods Salamis
built environment was able to withstand
the coercive policies of modernization
and ethno national chauvinism salomon
was not unique for former arab towns and
villages throughout israel from haifa to
load safa to Jerusalem became part of
Israel's rural and urban landscape even
as housing blocks became the dominant
feature of new neighborhoods and towns
contrary to traditional historiography
and despite a stark imbalance of power
the encounter between the block in the
Arab house was not a zero-sum game and
they hope to establish a new spatial
order by the abolition of another was
bound to encounter significant strains
and constraints in the in the 1950s the
construction of block gained pace
throughout the country as well as around
solomun the effect of these projects was
not however a mass relocation of
population and the abolition of the Arab
village instead this process created a
contained zone in which the foreign Arab
spatial order continues to exist in the
ha in the heart of Tel Aviv's
southeastern suburbs in the eyes of
state bodies responsible for the design
of appropriate urban environments
Salamis houses were more than an eyesore
they were and still are a disruptive
obstacle for the modernizing mission to
create a homogenous urban space that
abides by a stringent set of aesthetic
social and political conventions a
powerful portrayal of the spatial
opposition between the tenements and the
Arab houses and settlement is depicted
in a small leaflet published by hamishe
the national municipal housing company
formed in 1961 to administer the
reconstruction of slums in the Tel Aviv
area the leaflet invites residents in
fell Shalem to extinct exchange their
houses for apartments in a nearby
tenement project the leaflet text and
images provide
a characteristic narrative where one
environment is juxtaposed to the other
visually what seems to be an Arab house
in a state of dilapidation is set
against an image of a street lined with
housing blocks on both sides the latter
image presents what Plantard aspired
would become a quintessential Israeli
neighborhood with street lighting
sidewalks and communal recreation spaces
between the buildings the text
accompanying the image does not break
from the opposition established by the
images and construct contrasts the dire
physical condition and overpopulation of
Arab houses with the promise of a modern
sanitized space and the official
vocabulary of the time sanitation also
became synonymous with political
socialization removing at once health
risks and perceived social perils thus
for example Israel's Labour Minister in
the 1950s Golda Meir stated and I quote
good citizenship a real sense of
belonging the beginning of integration
in other words the creation of a good
society depended on the over one
dependent to an overwhelming degree on
how people live end quote in the case of
photo/lm however the process of
sanitizing the built environment proved
to be considerably more ambiguous
instigating social conflict and
challenge that challenged the underlying
logic of social political and spatial
standardization instead of a simple
negation resulting in physical
destruction the encounter between the
housing block in the Arab house exposed
the fractures in the Israeli states
modernizing machine and opened a space
for critical ethnic and social
realization by solemnise residents
mostly working class Jews of Arab and
North African descent several issues
hampered the authorities effort some
residents feared that financial
incentives and government loans would be
inadequate to cover the relocation costs
others realize the value of the land and
refused to give up their rights without
significant compensation all knew that
the crudely construction crudely
constructed three to four storey blocks
with their modest flats and neglected
communal areas were far from ideal
despite their often dilapidated States
state the Arab houses became an
increasingly viable if imperfect
solution for those who sought affordable
housing in the country's main metropolis
against the rigid form of block
apartments the Arab houses proved to be
malleable structures that could be
expanded divided and modified as such
the arab environment provided the
conditions for an alternative social
economy housing extended families and
giving rise to a gray market of sublets
and semi-official tendencies by the
mid-1960s eviction and reconstruction
effort reached a practical standstill to
salvage the project from complete
collapse the company management managing
it began taking legal action against
residents of Arab houses some were
deemed invaders to government property
others accused of violating the terms of
their tenancy by making illegal
modifications to the dilapidated
structures usually fixing a roof or a
drain the residents retort was immediate
instigating public petitions and toward
the mid-70s heated demonstrations these
actions claim chimed with
contemporaneous social and cultural
protest movements in Israel such as the
Israeli Black Panthers a group Ford
formed in the musalla neighborhood of
Jerusalem and 71 by young Jewish men of
North African descent who fervently
protested against the institutional
discrimination by the Ashkenazi dominant
establishment indeed the specter of the
Black Panthers is traceable and appeals
written bike fall Shalom residents in
the early 1970s as a potentially
explosive threat that might materialize
if the conflict between the
authorities and the residents is not
appropriately addressed in one of these
letters for example the warning is
clearly stated the perpetuation of these
in justins in justices right the
colossal m residents council will give
birth to Panthers in action or intention
and will bring about distrust in
friction in the nation anyone in their
right mind can imagine what our soldiers
sons feel when they're when they return
home from the front and 73 and find out
what the state they are serving is
perpetrating is this not justice is
there not justice in the claim that
Eastern Jews are discriminated against
appropriate housing is the foundation
for any healthy society even when the
threat of violent action against the
establishment and sounded it is with
careful attention to its position on the
boundaries of the imagined death no
national community each sentence is an
expression of ambiguity both reaffirming
the speakers belonging to and alienation
from the defining features of Israeli
mainstream society in the 1970s the
threatening rise of Panthers and a
concern for national integrity the
sacrifice of the residents through their
participation and military service
against the backdrop of state neglect
and perhaps most strikingly and
insistence on challenging on an
insistence to challenge reclaim and
redefine what a healthy society means
despite explicit discrimination this
last point goes beyond a typical
complaint about municipal services to
question the defining characteristics of
the Israeli society as a whole as such
it reflects a broad political agenda
with far-reaching objectives yet it is
crucial to note that these challenges
were not made against the general
abstract sense of socio-economic or
ethnic discrimination what sparked these
explosive ethnics social grievances were
the great blocks that surrounded salomon
described in the petition later on as
modern ghettos and later as residential
match boxes by the end of the 1970s the
blocks have had the block has already i
dented was already identified as a
modern transit camp on pillars
symbolizing the complete erosion of the
social economic and aesthetic ideals
that were responsible for its initial
ascent the hegemonic perception of the
housing block is the socializing machine
for the modeling of good citizens is
reversed and becomes a rallying cry in
the struggle over conventions of
citizenship equality and spatial
cultural identification perhaps
unknowingly the writers reiterate golda
mayor's association between housing and
social order only to challenge the
epistemic Allah thority that defines the
conventional terms governing Israel
socio political discourse social and
physical realities in Israel's first
three decades exposed the fallacy of
unrestricted state power operating in
empty space despite its roots and
modernist imagination of space the
Israeli housing block was never simply
dropped into a pristine white emptiness
as the map I opened it tries to imagine
nor for that matter did its appearance
result in the complete annihilation of
the our built environment instead the
production of a national space appears
as a laborious and unfinished process of
encounter and negotiation a constant
effort to mend the fractures that
emerged once political and aesthetic
ideals are exposed to the corrosive
power of spatial praxis and human
intervention the space that opens
literally and theoretically between the
Arab house and the tenement block who
provides a unique and important Vista
where new social and political
alternatives can emerge into view it is
often not a pretty or dramatic sight
usually found in peripheral
neighborhoods and in Israel's poverty
belts as such it tends to escape common
preoccupation with the housing block and
the spatial politics that
moded it as the case of Salamis shows
shifting the analytical focus from
idealistic manifestos to the actualities
and practices of space is a crucial step
toward the more complex understanding of
both architectural and political
dynamics considering spatial processes
beyond the overwhelming grip of the
state or the modern illuminates the
intricate relation between ethnic
political contestation in Israel and
former Arabs faces that become part of
its urban landscapes events like the
Black Panthers protests in saw and 71
and the intense clashes between
residents and the authorities in Solomon
throughout the 1970s are pivotal moments
that illustrate this unsettled history
to fully grasp the historical
relationship between architecture and
the state and Israel's first decades we
need to account for these as political
engagements that articulate broad social
and economic agendas in seemingly
mundane sites like Solomon in quite the
same way that the housing blocks and the
Arab houses in the village remain far
from their idealized forms neither an
Orientalist fantasy nor a purely
functional living machine the political
horizons that and contingent identities
that emerged in the year in their midst
do not adhere to the conventions that
continue to guide Israel's political
mainstream and its detractors it's not
an outright rejection of modernity
nation nation hood or capitalism but an
effort of individuals and groups to
engage as equals in the processes that
define the spaces they call their home
thank
Thanks no um our third speaker today is
Isla Lucifer who is currently teaching
at Indiana University in Bloomington
where he's a visiting faculty in the
department about history and the Center
for the Study of change he's also taught
in the the HTC department at MIT where
he received his PhD from in 2007 and he
also holds a masters of architecture
degree from Princeton where I actually
first met him about 15 years ago and
immediately recognized a certain
brilliance and this I just learned he
also holds a undergraduate degree in
mathematics and physics from the
University of Punjab in Lahore in
Pakistan he's currently working on a
book based on his dissertation that
looks at how Modern architects and
planners played a critical role in
shaping the third world development
discourse and its associated structures
of power an intervention in the post-war
era is Las paper today is titled
designed transitions ecosure doxy
artists and the refugee housing projects
under military rule in Pakistan 1953 to
1959 welcome
first want to thank the conference
organizers for putting together a
wonderful event and of course Felicity
for a generous introduction and also the
excellent comments on the paper
hopefully I'll be able to clarify some
of the points so as the title indicates
it's can you guys pay me in the back
there it's a story of two projects
akasha and doc CRS both were invited to
design refugee housing projects in
Pakistan under military rule in in the
50s one of them is made a doxy our
essence which is the later one Akasha
was invited first but that project is
not scrapped in after initial planning
stages but I would argue that boo
looking at both or contrasting them is
aborted to understand what modes of
power and control were able to take hold
or were viable in post-colonial
development contexts such as pakistan's
so let me jump right in on May twentieth
how do I move the images or on May
twentieth nineteen sixty three some
150,000 residents of the newly built
karongi housing colony in Karachi said
outside their houses with their
belongings hosting black flags to
protest the eviction of one use of
product from his house by the Karachi
Development Authority the KD at any
other location the protesters would have
been dispersed with the baton if not the
bulldozer karongi however had special
status it was built by the military
government of a Yukon the self-appointed
appointed Field Marshal and president of
Pakistan from nineteen fifty eight to
nineteen sixty nine eleven years as a
model housing project for refugees from
India that had crowded the streets of
Karachi since the partition of the
subcontinent in 1947 after the end of
the British ooh a clash with those
refugees groups now would have these
lucema is the project as well as the
government that celebrated it a
confrontation would have also said have
been a setback for the two American aid
agencies the US aid and the ford
foundation that had sponsored the
project as an experiment in two scored
social pacific
designed to save Karachi is large
migrant and refugee population from
spreading community v'ed spreading
communist influence these concerns were
not lost to the project designer the
famous greek architect planner and
global consultant par excellence at the
time constantine doxiadis in a letter to
the military director of the national
housing and settlement agencies and the
fourth foundation representative in
karachi doxiadis road and incidentally
he looks very much like the you bitch
maybe that's why they like each other in
the four and half years of my
acquaintance with the urban problems of
Pakistan it is the first time that I
have seen such an enthusiasm inspiration
and coordination of effort under a
unique command for the achievement of a
natural goal in this field the operation
karongi as I think it should be called
has all the characteristics of a
beachhead started by commandos in
hostile territory but commandos who have
the desire to achieve a national goal
even by deciding to have greater
sacrifices and casualties than normally
even more it should be turned into the
beachhead that is going to open the
enemy land for conquest doxiadis his
statement betrays the farming
justification of authoritarian rule the
public as the enemy that must be fought
in the present so that the nation could
be preserved in the future more
importantly however I would argue it
shows how this duality is managed by
casting modernization as a natural goal
all political change challenges are
framed as unnatural forces that must be
fought with unshakable resolve the
authoritarian rule bears the
responsibility of a sacred custodianship
of standing above the unnatural realm of
politics to enable the nation to follow
an inherent natural process of change
the you government itself had framed the
project in similar terms when he
described as part of its called basic
democracy program the program had banned
all national politics with the claim
that public first needed to be caught
train in politics through participation
only at the municipal levels this
process of incremental political
training placed great emphasis on
administrative structures this focus
love the military government to forge a
working alliance with the Pakistan with
Pakistan's influential civil bureaucracy
extending the latter's power and giving
the military government a civil face the
question of refugee settlement was a
critical component in consolidating this
alliance the partition of India of
Pakistan had been unpredictable as you
heard in another's talk had been both
unpredictable and violent displacing
more than 12 million people in leaving
over a million debt a major factor of
this toll had been the unpredictability
of the partition itself concerning if
and how the heterogeneous population of
the subcontinent would be divided into
Hindu and Muslim majority nation-states
so this is the political set up at the
part of at the point of the partition
with yellow states show that how the
subcontinent was not under all under
direct British rule but yellow states
were princely states and they were
supposed to decide which side they would
go on casting or contributing
unpredictability to the whole process
says he heard for this uncertainty was
driven on the one hand by the British
haste to do a colonization with the
minimum political cost and on the other
hand by the failure of the major
political parties of the independence
struggle to come to an agreement on the
sharing of power as the deadlines of
major deadlines or for independence
approached this is the last Viceroy mode
button making clear that there is a
deadline millions who had been hoping to
be on the right side of the border found
themselves turned into refugees in their
own homes the ensuing violence and
dislocation would come to be best
remembered in the post-war political
culture on both sides of the border to
the photographs of Margaret bourke-white
which you've seen some of these images
before the famous American
photojournalist known for an Kenya for
her uncanny ability to be present before
unfolding catastrophes
she had been present at the allied
liberation of the bush involve
concentration cap in 1945 and had been
and had taken the famous image of Gandhi
at the spinning wheel hours before his
assassination and was now present in
India before the partition as well in
book wise images and you've seen some of
these but I want to mention a specific
quality of these images with which I
argue i'm arguing resonates in the
political culture after the partition in
brooke white images of the partition one
characteristic stands out the
juxtaposition of opposing skills the
grand and the immediate the national and
personal distraught faces are set
against black whiskers grand vistas
blank skies and historical sites like
this image of the boy in the daily
fourth it is as if the partition had
opened a chasm that had swallowed all
that mediated between the personal and
the national bringing the former
integrating agency with the letter
without the intervening layers of the
social the common the familial and the
familiar but quite stress this force
coupling by highlighting the
overburdened and inadequate means of
transportation or makeshift objects
employed to make the historical crossing
the inadequacy of the means available to
meet this historical and special
challenge give the images and air of
incertitude the refugees appeared to us
not only to be passing through a
catastrophic transition but also appear
as if they would remain forever caught
in this moment and indeed they would
this transitory status would continue to
define the idea of refugee national
politician Allah litical discourse even
when they have reached their
destinations and some of these images
the one earlier would be present in doxy
addresses report in the chrony project
as well the representative figures of
this transition would come to be would
be the refugees in karachi so this map
karachi is right here in the south first
capital of pakistan right after the
partition before it was moved to islam
but also designed by doxiadis majority
of these refugees had migrated from
court encode all do speaking areas in
India
and n as such did not belong to any of
the historical ethnic and linguistic
groups that were sutured together into
Pakistan's four provinces and
independence because of the Karachi
refugee because the Karachi refugees
left any provincial association they
soon acquired the curious status of
permanent refugees within the country
the refugee in Karachi presented an
empowered and impartial and transit
researcher because she appeared outside
of national politics she rendered the
politics of associations and alliances
transparent her future represented or
could be claimed to represent the
nation's feature growing on this framing
the youth government deployed the
project of refugee settlement to justify
a through it framed refugee settlement
as a project of carefully guided process
of national transformation that demanded
administrative custodianship rather than
political representation under the
quote-unquote basic democracy program
the transitory status of the refugees
were projected onto the entire country
turning the entire population as
refugees in democratic politics doxiadis
had judged the judge these larger
political requirements correctly
describing his designs from the
beginning as open-ended and transitory
cotton coat processes rather than
concrete plans each project emphasized
systematic coordination of parts and
incremental growth just to find
long-term administrative control this
approach one him several projects from
the youth government including the
Commission for the new capital of
Pakistan Islamabad in 1962 karangi
however was not the first attempt at
settling settling the refugee population
in Karachi doxiadis was a late comer on
this scene it was Mitchell Akasha the
director of town planning of the french
protectorate in morocco who was first
invited to design refugee colonies in
karachi in 1953 echo shows project for
karachi however was not realized unable
to take hole in the turbulent political
political climate of the time yet for
our purposes it highlights just as
importantly as doc sierra since later
proposal the viability of different
models of intervention and change in
relation to particular structures of the
state Akasha had arrived in Karachi as a
UN consultant on the recommendation of
earnest Wiseman and active
remember and the head of the UN housing
and planning section in New York this
recommendation was based on echo shows
recent experience with designing
transitions akosha and other members of
at beths announcement of an offshoot had
completed a massive housing project in
casablanca on the outskirts of
casablanca for the incoming migrant
population a project highly praised at
the recent recent meeting of CM in
either province for staging a dialogue
between quote between the poles of code
culture and function the buildings
supposedly replaced the formal elements
of the natives environment such as the
terraces and courtyards in a modern
idiom but did so along in decreasing
density arrangements as the inhabitants
supposedly there was arguin as the
inhabitants moved from high to low
density they acquired modern
sensibilities and living and living
habits without a certain break in their
cultural practices that's the famous
diagram on the CM grill which shows
anthropological profiles you know
drawing on colonial anthropology of how
these people living in higher densities
in native environment moved to you know
modern profiles of the basic family unit
but then they are at the same time moved
to lower density arrangements in this
equation function was seen to intervene
at fixed moments nudge culture the
colonial authorities appeared as both
modernize errs and preservationists the
dual focus often dismissed as
schizophrenic in historical analysis I
would argue however forms a particular
mode of colonial administration so
usually an analysis seen as well their
current authorities are you know
emphasized dual focus on the one hand
they want to say you know colonial
science function all these things are
important but on the other hand they
want to preserve you know native
cultural environment so the whole
discourse of association in French
colonial Imperial policy but and usually
that is dismissed at all the colonizers
weren't able to decide you know which is
more important colonial science or
preservation is strength but what if we
take the dual stands as a colonial
administrative policy itself
schizophrenic stands which serves a
particular purpose
under the regime of enclosing our album
forms a particular mode of colonial
administration under the regime of
cotton cord inclusive French colonialism
modernity was present as a project was
presented as a project of only
periodically calibrating the movements
of loosely defined buried and dispersed
cultural sphere of the French Imperial
domains perpetuated in the name of
protecting native population from sudden
influence of modernization this dual
approach allowed colonial administrators
to take both a preservationist and
transformative stance emphasizing the
dimension demanded demanded by the
circumstance preservationist if Labour
reserves were required transformative
displacements were warranted so if you
want to modernize displaced people you
can say you're modernizing that if you
want to have leveled labor reserve you
say you're preserving the culture Okocha
deemed that such a dual emphasis was
suitable for framing the process of
refugee settlements in Pakistan as well
and he shows the image of Casablanca
housing in the UN report for Augustana
it made visible the authority of the
government as the agent of change but
frame that agency as sympathetic and a
distant one so it only intervenes at
moments to transform the nudge them a
little bit echo shows initial proposal
for Karachi constituted of a series of
Independence satellite Scott encode
cities at Landy a site adjacent to which
will be doxy addresses future karungi
project these cities were to be
developed over time along the main
railway line that link Karachi to the
outline industrial areas this multiple
city approach however quickly change to
a more centralized design comprising of
a single large city with multiple quote
unquote neighborhoods though each of
these units were to have a fixed
periphery and a fixed framework of road
shopping centers schools etc they were
meant to accommodate and they were meant
to accommodate changing types and
arrangements of housing in large swathes
of open green to close up maybe this one
so this is one of the neighborhood's I
think one of their in the corner what's
curious is that different neighborhoods
are shown having
you know at different moments in the
development of the scheme and having
different types of housing slowly
evolving from one to the next as the
inhabitants are modernized what's
curious here is that Okocha does not
settle on a particular organizing scheme
for the houses until the very end in
fact there's another arrangement in fact
the very possibility of ever new
reorganization is presented as the main
feature of the plan following Casablanca
I should have expected the new city to
grow from provision area shelter to
enter it to an intermediate stage of
ground floor houses two high-rise blocks
that could be arranged and rearranged in
different conglomerations with an open
space as the economic and social profile
of the inhabitants change over time
akasha argued the entire settlement
would move towards lower density and
more open space at currently this
process comes to be articulated in the
language of CMS for functions of
circulation work living in public
facilities the last modified here as a
care of body and spirit to include a
mosque and a hospital in Palestine the
four functions announced in advance the
profile of a modern life whose
particular details are to be revealed in
time the city is literally imagined as a
palimpsest of these different functional
layers each influencing nudging the
process of cultural change towards a
process of incremental modernization the
city forms an infrastructural field that
is both the condition of transformation
of its contents and their tilos the
moment when the transforming environment
would catch up with the full potential
of the framework the scheme outlines a
process of evolution whose final form is
already visible we witness only the
process of filling in the details so the
main concern for extra is outlining the
boundary first the boundary becomes this
representation visible making visible
the authority or the agency of the state
and whatever inside you know it's a slow
transformative process I mean that can
happen over time but it is important for
him to represent what the
social agency or agency of social reform
is in this case and this is the idea of
state as a singular power extra extended
the logic dis logic to map the entire
city of Karachi mapping its density as
indicative of different stages of
modernization of the inhabitants and how
they could be set on path to the next
stage under the guidance of a
comprehensive and comprehensive
comprehensive and visible administrative
framework Erica shless approach could
not find the same currency in Pakistan
as it had laid in Casablanca in Pakistan
the idea of central authority could not
being invoked with the same ideological
wait as in colonial context a design
emphasizing the need for a comprehensive
and visible armature of organization
however open produced the opposite
effect making the very power made
visible through the project open to
attack in a protected exchange xtracab
accusing the refugee settlement agency
of ignoring the comprehensive nature of
the plan and picking and choosing
individual parts for piecemeal
implementation very soon the project
came to be framed in the political
debate as an idealized scheme beyond the
means of developing nation and
disconnected from local concerns and
politics so echo shows project failed
precisely because I mean his strategy
off you know outlining the visible or
the agency of change comes under attack
because it has no historical legitimacy
in Bach's Toccata let me now quickly
turn to project take a sit
the most striking difference the most
striking difference between a duck Cyrus
an actual plan is the different approach
to boundaries akosha plan had placed
this is crunk his plan and of course its
characteristic of Roxy irises approach
of two bands one is institutional and
one is sort of light industry and filled
in with so this is community buildings
light industry and then neighborhoods in
between of different community classes
and this was where a crucial project was
supposed to be so doc serious plan was
supposed to eventually cannibalize it as
it moved in this direction Hector plan
had placed particular emphasis on the
elimination of clear boundaries for his
proposed refugee settlements the
proposal by Doc's layer is formed Roxy
RSM sucx on the other hand purported to
an idea of continuous expansion so the
plan was supposed to grow like this is
like Napoleon's army marching doxy iris
proposed settlement was to grow linearly
over time out of his present side and
direct the growth of the entire city of
Karachi this approach I would argue
reflects a different idea of
consolidating state power than the one
proposed by Porsche I'm going to speed
up a little in setting a predefined
scale for the entire project Okocha
designated the state as the ultimate
agent of change in contrast doc CRS is
approaching eradicated the fixed
boundaries of the plan works toward
erasing precisely the scale at which the
state made itself visible as the agent
of social reform the scheme proposed the
Nestle model going back to the diagram
the plan the scheme proposed a Nestle
model of social organization controlled
by disseminated administrative structure
without an unidentifiable authority the
population was to be divided into
different community sectors each one
here beginning with the basic income
unit of community class 1 and ending
with the community class 5 the structure
was to be administered jointly by
cooperative bowls of members of
government agencies and surrounding
industries in the past if the government
or the industry provided direct housing
to the workers on mortgage the instead
of paying down the debt had held that as
employment security so you know if you
have dad instead of you no one can fire
you in a sense
so but to counter that they said we'll
just you know disseminate the authority
so you can't really have an identifiable
authority that you can challenge karangi
is nestled special organization in
disseminated administrative structure
made it virtually impossible to
challenge any policy on a limited scale
while making coordinated affections
expedient now Roxy Eris is often accused
of abstracting traditional architectural
elements such as and this these are the
houses or such as the courtyards or wind
screen into standardized elements
rearranged 12 grades for logistical
convenience such that they lose the
social even climatic purpose indeed
karongi appears to fit the bill as well
yet this criticism in celebrating the
station and symbolic qualities of the
cultural space repeats the underlying
assumption of doxy addresses abstracting
enterprise culture as a self-regulating
non oppressive and transparent
structures appear for doxiadis to the
statistical universe set up on
standardized grid presented a set of
abstracted form being necessary to
introduce a new set of market-based
choices to the inhabitants different
income classes communities were provided
lot sizes which are more or less the
same this uniformity sought to provide
the inhabitants with the equal potential
to build credit as expand their houses
built credit against the house as they
expand the structures setting the basis
for a consumer industrial economy it was
assumed however that if these choices
referred even tangentially to the
cultural idiom of inhabitants so there
is a courtyard there you know and it
there the tangential and abstracted
references to culture link they would
appear intelligible sorry to cultural
idiom of the enable sense they would
appear intelligible to them so culture
leaning in the background as distance
reference in the form of dislocated
courtyard or a modernised minaret this
was seen to provide a safety net a
training ground for entry into the
market karangi was a consumer purgatory
of sorts where the inhabitants were
presented with market choices in
cultural terms it's not the presence of
statistics per se that makes exercise of
power possible here but the idea of
culture as the necessary foil for
understanding them this duality was
fundamentally doxy are a statistics the
science of human settlement kiss the
flag off switch
basis for different so-called cultural
environments serving as a bridge between
presume pools of tradition and modernity
and this was precisely by acoustics
gained enormous currency in territorial
governments like Pakistan it framed on
the one hand modernization as a problem
of transition list amaizing
authoritarian rule as custodian of this
process yet on the other hand it
presented this transitory moment to be
driven by the individuals choices a
particular idea of consumer is
constructed in their kiss t'kul world
one who is available for adventures in
the market since he has given the choice
to expand the house but since those
choices he can only understand in the
cultural context but declared unprepared
for those in politics a consumer who can
only understand the language of culture
culture becomes an alibi afore pushing
entry into the market while delaying
entry into politics it must be stressed
here again that at currently these
displacements are carried out through
the figure of the refugee who in the
context of post partition Pakistan is
tied to the ideas of socio-cultural
transition refugee is a subject who can
host the idea of delay in political
representation perpetually appearing in
need for soft modernization cast in the
language language of culture she is
constantly seen as out of sync with the
action in the National Theatre
especially when the play on stage is
declared to be market capitalism Roxy
iris and ayub government did not
consider however the such delaying
strategies could not be continually
continually masked with architecture as
karangi protest sure the very sight of
suppose a transition could just as
easily be turned into sites of social
organization and claiming the system of
perpetual transition as when of
Perpetual crisis it would however take
almost another decade a tainted election
and in economic crisis for the political
opposition to mobilize the mass protest
that would eventually unseat oh you can
get the inherent political crisis of
Pakistan stemming from attempts to keep
I think and linguistic divisions in
check through centralized control would
continue to resurface in the preceding
decades and still continue what is
critical to note in this reiterate
reiterating crisis of power is the
manner in which the International and
the Nash
embed themselves with within each other
to advance their agendas rather than
imposing them independently development
is often simply seen as a form of New
Imperialism imposed from the outside an
external power imposes his will on a
subjugated society as we have seen this
model of oppressor oppressed does not
adequately adequately explain the
mutually legitimizing modes of power in
the development arena just as it does
not explain the complexity of colonial
governance it is here that architecture
admiral projects such as dogs ers and
echo shows provide critical archives for
understanding the new and emerging modes
of intervention it is here that they
also retrieve a history or modern
architectures intimate relationship with
power in the postwar international
obviously there's a lot to talk about
from these papers that I actually
thought in the interest of keeping some
time for for audience questions that I
was just going to begin with one quite
general question it may appear to be a
slight lateral displacement although
actually pointed to this number of
points in in his remarks and I is
somewhat mythological question and so I
just wanted to ask if each of you could
speak to this question of the degree to
which the the focus of your research put
some pressure on the terms through which
architectural history is conventionally
a dress uniform own aesthetic questions
visual documents as a prevalent aspect
of its disciplinary purview and its
state and the question I guess is to
what extent these these dimensions about
historical scholarship yet aesthetically
formal remain relevant or a
fundamentally sort of transformed pushed
in a different direction when one
participates the discourse invested in
tracing sort of shift from paradigms of
representation to those of course of
administration and management and how
then these forces that it traces how
they or how these forces force of
administration and management that
foucauldian sense can be read can
continue to be read as legible or
visible and what sort of discursive
tools then we might need in order to to
address those and certainly to address
them in individual register yes you know
their complexity and it's not supposed
to be a trick question but more sort of
platform to ask each of you to speak to
the sort of critical and mythological
stakes as they push back on the field of
architectural history you know as such
so in any order just as an opening
gesture and then we'll open it up to
more specific questions
the audience so maybe in the order that
we began anew no we're talking about not
alphabetical oh no I I mean I haven't I
have agonized a little bit over this
question in the writing of this paper
unlike the other two people on my panel
but topic that I spoke about today isn't
actually my primary line of research but
I find that my interest is in refugees
and I find you don't you can't you can't
think about an architecture related to
refugees without thinking about the law
the real estate law behind them or any
other sort of law so I've certainly
danced around this problem as I was
writing this paper that can you write in
architectural history paper that is
effectively a paper about real estate
law and I think I received many
assurances that you can but it's an
awkward moment I think just because this
is a field in a sort of transition but I
do think that I see the opportunity for
architectural historians to to kind of
take ownership of that problem I don't
think it's really been done until
recently yeah I mean I guess the the
explicit question I was trying to to
address regarding the the traditional
periodization and and kind of opposite a
traditional position between these two
forms of housing that i was i was
discussing is of course intended
directly at those there's sort of the
traditional historiography of
architectural history in israel however
obviously this this this seems to sort
of also there some some some implication
on on the hidden protagonist as it were
of this of this page book paper which is
exactly the
what is the the degree of responsibility
of residence in sort of the the current
Jewish residents in Solomon and as well
elsewhere in Israel for the those
refugees who are not there and exactly
that also we're not there in any of your
images I mean in terms of the visual
rhetoric or exact paper they are not
there simply because they're basically
until 1967 they don't have that they
mostly don't have access to these places
from the West Bank and after 67 there's
I mean there's a history of those trips
back into and that again encounter which
is not spatial and not architectural in
nature but I think that question of
custodianship that was raised here and
and and if we try to think of it the
challenge of custodianship not only on
on the level of official administration
but custodianship on the level of
residency that tension between
preservation and appropriation
maintenance and appropriation is one of
the big challenges that I think that
comes up from from that bad idea more
traditionally examples of modern
architecture
chromium contacts have been the showcase
examples of the curb ugh a nigger can't
stuck a Brazilian were on but and
monitor texture is only seen to you know
have shaped the national debate or post
colonial context so only symbolically
right i mean the business building may
represent something you know to the
extent that bring in you know Western
values and whatever I mean they are
oppressive on the other hand I mean
they're there there's a whole school of
thought that says that this was the good
thing and you know there are many people
like me you can speak good English
because of colonization and so there's
the so I mean depends which side you're
on but if the debate is limited to
symbolic value of whether symbolism was
appropriate or not states claim yeah
modernization for architecture yeah
that's the correct function what's mrs.
that I mean before these captives were
made i mean there's a whole discourse in
richer than during World Bank whatever
the whole development dis was in which
their nations were very much invested
and international institutions were very
much invested and they were bringing in
architects to set up processes which
cannot be represent you i mean the
buildings in some cases were not even
met I mean it's just plain enzyme your
pores which is circulating stuff so how
can architectural history now look at
these archives and understand architects
I mean that's very much visual their
images they're not building sure but
they nevertheless serve the purpose of
giving meaning to which are very complex
processes of organization with multiple
you know causes they give them meaning
as if these are manageable processes
right there nevertheless open-ended and
you can't the don't drink and in five
who's controlling them and whatever but
this set them up as manageable processes
these these archives up I think
traditionally
no time for you know historians do not
in any way intended to suggest the the
ongoing relevance of a sort of
uncontested paradigm of history but to
ask you know how these types of
interventions remaining dialogue to the
point that they can actually be legible
as interventions as well so this is you
know this is exactly that I think that's
at stake in negotiating yeah both spaces
and not not losing some aspects of one's
expertise but certainly not foreseeing a
new body of material in questions into
that whole paradigm so this is the
discussion but I'm sure there many
questions I want to write I think
there's a microphone wandering around
well thank you a great panel grade
papers and and I this is actually a
question that I was thinking about in
the morning really with respect to both
panels and and you've really helped to
all three of you helped to focus I hope
in useful ways this is the question it
prospers I'll tell you what it's not a
question it's enough it's not a question
about like changing the name of the
conference isn't in a sense to
architecture and nationalism but it is a
question about the relationship between
nation and state you know to with an
emphasis on relationship you know in
terms of let's say culture politics in
terms of you know representation and
production or Android administration of
bodies and space etc so it seems to me
that if we are in relation to the
discussion you're just having if we are
to sort of contemplate and sense new
tools for new problems right that that
this would be one of those discursive
tools we would need to sharpen in other
words the capacity to specify
architectures multiple functions within
that relationship so I'm interested to
know what thought you might have about
I was thinking this earlier as well
we've been mentioning the idea of state
and there has been discussion that you
know state as this you know it's not a
monolithic thing the boundaries are
porous a nevertheless and you know there
it was sort of letting in all these
characters which are criticizing it and
sort of it was more insidious operating
more insidiously by letting the people
who are criticizing it into its fold but
even that idea assumes that there is
some sort of central nerve center you
know someone sitting finger on the
button in controlling what okay lettin
you know these critics now and will you
know able to expand our territory a
little bit and stuff state is I mean is
really a network of people sitting in
institutional context without any
central deciding bodies and there's a
lot of unpredictability and you know
accidental developments and agenda is
competing agendas so if we get rid of
the idea of you know a sort of central
decision-making body then you have to
account for you know intersections that
it's the biographical intersecting with
you know the institutional agendas with
you know whatever regional agenda is
political agenda is at play at the
moment so ideas of mission and instead
basically i would say state is sort of
this bureaucratic set up on which I
different ideas of nations of nation are
propped up on to give it meaning state
is always sort of has this functioning
dimension I mean it is it never makes
itself in my mind visible as the state
so to speak is it always has to have
some of you know historical dimension
and nation is precisely where the
history comes in and gives state meaning
as cohesive pneus but in a very
unpredictable discontinuously I I would
actually add a just I agree with that
completely and I but the thing I kept
running into is that this idea of nation
as a as a landscape of imagination as
well it's
really just I mean I the there's this
component of bureaucracy to state and I
think it has a mirror in nation they're
both obviously political in
constructions but there's a there's a
sense of architecture as of as a method
for enabling imagination when you talk
about nation that I think struck me in
working on this yeah I mean I what I
found really challenging is the the way
that working in the spatial archive
enables us to understand literally the
concrete temporality and and and the gap
of the temporal gap between exactly
national imagination and it's it's it's
prolonged and protracted implementation
and all the possibilities that that that
opens up
I mean I think in the post colonial
context that there's a set of other
questions that go along with this but
maybe this isn't the right moment there
will be a lot of chances to talk perhaps
you can see mission is the narrative
through which the steel captures the
subject yeah that is necessarily needed
and whites point I have a question to
know you mentioned that there was sort
of clear aesthetic or cultural aspect to
the judgment which settlements which
abandoned of displaced Arab settlements
to destroy and which to develop those
tourist areas could you talk a little
bit on on the criterias and those
aesthetic criteria which were put into
this decision and maybe who produced
this great theories architects or urban
planners or politicians I think that
ties really well with the question of
imagination and how do how do we how do
we use that that sort of physical
archive to expose that exactly the
criteria of imagining nationhood I think
in the Israeli case it was it was a
combined effort of both architects
planners and and political ideologues
the the term the the boundaries between
these kind of professional categories
were extremely blurry as I hope Sevilla
thoughts is going to talk about tomorrow
about the exactly the participation of
Architects in the production and
imagination of space but I guess what is
interesting and is just to note the
tension in the Israeli case between old
and new and
and the effort to on the one hand
trumpet modern ideals and modern
imaginations of space with the
recreation of the sort of a biblical
ideal of sovereignty and how to bridge
that gap literally bridge the gap
between biblical times in contemporary
era while cleaning away as it were
sometimes physically the those
discrepancies that could not be
conveniently compartmentalised into into
either that is on the grand scale but as
as I think it shows there was a lot of
uncertainty especially in those first
years about where exactly one draws the
borders between old and new and and what
exactly constitutes then the old that
develops and the new and that also
touches but with an Arab heritage with
in architecture which Israel and parotid
from from Arab settlements how did they
draw the border within this heritage
what to destroy and what to live again
this is a this is a question that
the answer is it depends when we're in
the archive in the archive you look and
and and who you consult when trying to
answer that the debates are uncertain
there are various proposals on using for
example creating a museum for the arab
architecture of palestine and that was
apropos the proposal that was discussed
by the archaeological authorities in the
early days of israel those were never
carried out and destruction was often
carried out spontaneously by army units
or used as sort of training grounds in
the 1950s and 60s on the other hand and
suddenly you get the mosque that was
turned into a youth club again usually
following practical considerations on
the ground on very low level
administrative decision makers by low
level decision makers and not by not
according to this some grand scheme of
things
I just want to know just you to pick up
on the questions very briefly it's
interesting because the village was not
destroyed right so it's somehow embodies
the right of return in a way I don't
know if you it's as if it could be read
as a sort of monument for the right to
return in a certain way insofar as it's
one of the videos that were not
destroyed so another reading that could
provide it's not just against
modernization but in a more sort of like
story call you know more you know view
of like starting from from 48 and then
in the village and the mosque remains
there although it's been use it as a
your Center you know it's it's still the
Palestinian village I don't know if you
if you could read in that way as a
monument a sort of a historical monument
of absurd political claim that continues
monumental ization is as I discovered in
latter stages my research is a very
dangerous a term when when one discusses
the forces that enable preservation
because i'll just briefly note the
history of the mosque the youth club
that was open than the mosque was closed
an 81 and the mosque stood empty
actually stands empty until today but
following the eruption of the the second
palestinian uprising d fada in two
thousand and october two thousand one
one evening residents of the
neighborhood set out with hammers and
axes and began tearing the mosque down
and that is twenty years after it was
standing empty and in some way that
moment was a moment when the mosque was
no longer a youth club is no longer
integrated into networks very practical
and mundane network
of life but regained its monumental
status as it were and sort of invited a
monumental violence against it very
familiar from exactly examples that we
know in Paris or or in Delhi for that
matter the reappropriation of symbolic
sites so and about the question of the
right of return I think it's these yes
that's that's i think it's a it's a huge
question maybe maybe we'll we'll address
it afterwards if that's okay i know i
know i know this is a brief question I
was curious I want to ask Anna Ratna she
could comment on ish Laos reading of
Margaret bourke-white photographs since
we have that overland oh I why I have to
say I'm actually very glad that he
brought it up because I had to cut
something out of this paper and I
couldn't get into an analysis but I
completely agreed I mean she's an
interesting character in the history but
certainly the questions of visual
culture and the way that the nation was
mobilized in in popular literature and
her her photographs actually illustrated
the book that I showed that train to
pakistan which is a it's a it was a
romance and it was a romance written by
a journalist based on real events real
very tragic events but I mean she's a
that's a topic of its own really
you were not convinced she does do this
thing that you say though about bringing
the kind of the global and local into
thanks felicity well I've been hearing
about you from many corners oh very nice
to meet you we nice talk